In the words of music legend Whitney Houston
'Crack is Whack'.
But with all the extra attention lately, thanks
to Toronto Mayor Rob Ford - what exactly is
crack-cocaine?
Is it really as 'whack' as it's portrayed
to be?
Crack is simply another form of cocaine, which
comes from the leaves of a coca plant.
After mixing powdered cocaine with a weak
base, such as baking soda, it changes composition
and a solid is produced, often referred to
as 'rocks'.
This solid has a much lower melting point
than cocaine (90C vs 190C) allowing it to
be smoked, as opposed to snorted.
In fact, it's called 'crack' because of the
sound it makes when heated.
But why smoke it?
Well, the lungs are an extremely quick and
effective way of getting something into the
bloodstream.
Those with asthma, for example, use inhalers
to quickly put a drug directly into their
system.
When smoke meets the large surface area in
your lungs, it too slips right through the
membrane, and heads straight to your brain,
in as little as 8 seconds.
This is much faster and more intense than
the effects of snorted cocaine which generally
takes around 10 minutes to reach the brain.
However, once in the brain, crack and cocaine
are effectively identical.
Initially, users feel energized, alert and
much more aware of their senses.
In the brain, crack acts on the Ventral Tegmental
Area, releasing large amounts of dopamine
- the chemical often associated with feelings
of pleasure and euphoria.
This dopamine travels between brain cells
- called neurons - and binds to receptors
that trigger the good feelings.
Now, normally, this dopamine would be reabsorbed
back into the neuron by a dopamine transporter;
however, crack alters this process.
It attaches to the transporter, and blocks
the reabsorption, allowing dopamine to build
up and continually stimulate the receptors.
As a result, you feel - well - really good
for around 10 minutes.
But soon after, the dopamine levels in the
brain plummet, causing an extreme low and
often feelings of depression.
Which is why many users typically smoke more,
hoping to reach that high again.
Unfortunately, these dopamine levels can take
a long time to naturally replenish, contributing
to physical and psychological dependence or
addiction, as well as increased irritability,
restlessness and paranoia.
In some cases, crack or cocaine abuse can
lead to something called Delusional Parasitosis
- the feeling that bugs or insects are crawling
under the skin.
This often leads to self-destructive behaviour,
like scratching or biting, in an effort to
get rid of the imagined bugs.
In the most serious cases, crack's impact
on the heart can cause heart attacks, strokes,
or even stop the heart altogether, leading
to death.
Simply put, on the extreme end of things,
crack can get pretty whack!
Thanks to Audible.com for giving you a free
audio book of your choice at audible.com/asap.
Audible is the leading provider of audiobooks
with over 150,000 downloadable titles across
all types of literature.
One of our recent favorites is "Sycamore Row"
which is John Grisham's sequel to "A Time
to Kill".
You can download this audio book or another
of your choice, for free, at audible.com/asap.
Then use audibles free app to listen on your
apple, windows or android device.
Special thanks to audible for making these
videos possible and for offering you a free
audio book of your choice at audible.com/asap.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos.